hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
mache heute ein gebäck aus großmutters
zeiten und zwar kennt ihr vielleicht
alle dieses waffeleisen
deshalb war früher ganz gerne gemacht
heutzutage gibt es gar nicht mehr so
dass man waffeln damit auspackt und zwar
ist es auch er sonst an dynamisches
rezept da gibt's auch eine geschichte
dazu und zwar war es früher so dass man
dieses dieses waffeleisen von der
schwiegermutter geschenkt bekommen hat
zur hochzeit und zwar deswegen falls
sich mal spontan besuch ankündigt und
man hat keinen kuchen zu hause hat man
dieses rezept gemacht bisher nämlich
ganz wieder grundzutaten die man immer
zu hause hat und dann war es eben nicht
so peinlich das nächste heim hat sondern
man hat sich kurz in die küche gestellt
und eben diese waffeln ausgebacken und
ich mache diese waffen heute jetzt auch
und zeigt euch dafür kurz die zutaten
und zwar brauche ich 250 gramm mehl 60 g
zucker eine prise salz und etwas viel
extrakt vier eier und etwa 250
milliliter mädels das rezept geht auch
ziemlich einfach man braucht keine
küchenmaschine dazu sondern nur einen
schneebesen und ich führe jetzt zucker
und mehl in einer großen schüssel
er kommt noch das salz mit rein und dann
gebe ich noch die eier mit dazu und
etwas vanille extrakt
und verrührt ist es erstmal
und dann nehme ich mir immer von außen
etwas mehl und rührten teig klümpchen
frei das rezept könnte übrigens auch ein
türkisches rezept zeit bei uns ist
nämlich aus oder muss man immer was zu
hause haben wenn gäste kommen und meine
mama die hat auch immer was daheim bald
sich die zutaten verbunden haben gebe
ich jetzt langsam die milch mit rein
der teig ist jetzt schon fertig als ihr
seht es geht wirklich ganz schnell
innerhalb von ein bis zwei minuten habe
ich den teig zusammengerührt den muss
ich jetzt allerdings erst noch zehn
minuten stehen lassen und kann ihn dann
ausdrucken
ich habe jetzt in der zwischenzeit schon
mal etwas fett aufgesetzt und zwar
nämlich seit einem kokosfett weil man
das sehr hoch erhitzen kann und ihr
könnt mit einem holzstäbchen
kontrollieren ob die temperatur erreicht
ist wenn ihr das holzstäbchen reinsteckt
und wenn sich dann so kleine bläschen
drumherum middleton ihr solltet jetzt
nur aufpassen dass das fed jetzt nicht
zu heiß wird damit das gepäck nicht
verbrennt jetzt brauche ich das
waffeleisen in das feld ein
so wird jetzt erst mal erwärmt dafür so
etwa 20 sekunden
dann wird es in den teig eingetaucht und
da müsste jetzt darauf achten dass er es
nur bis zu drei viertel eintaucht so
jetzt wieder direkt zurück und so wird
es jetzt ausgebacken als er misst beim
eintauchen in den teig aufpassen dass
der teig nicht über dieses waffeleisen
geht sonst geht's nämlich nicht mehr
runter thema 5
löst sich die waffe von ganz alleine vom
waffeleisen dann nehmt ihr sie heraus
und gibt sie auf ein papier und dann
geht es einfach immer so weiter das war
fleisch schon heiß das heißt keine c
direkt eintauchen und wieder
zurückgezahlt
also die erste woche jeweils bis hin zu
dunkel
beim eintauchen müssen jetzt nur darauf
achten ihr drückt ja das waffeleisen
runter aber irgendwann löst sich dann
die waffen von ganz alleine das heißt
ihr könnt dann nach ein paar sekunden
schon das waffeleisen wegnehmen dann
einfach nur noch ganz kurz auspacken ist
es etwa karamell farben ist damit die
waffen jetzt auch gelingen sollte ein
paar dinge beachten und zwar taucht er
ja das waffeleisen in den teig ein und
erwartet ihr einfach 23 sekunden dann
wird der teig nämlich am waffeleisen
fest dann geht ihr hoch und dann direkt
in das heiße fett wenn man nämlich zu
früh hochgeht dann rutscht tag wieder an
dem fertigen waffeleisen runter und dann
gelingt es nicht und was ihr auch
beachten ist so wie vorhin schon erwähnt
dass der teig eben nicht übers reisen
geht bei uns passiert nämlich folgendes
wenn es einmal drüber geht dann kriegt
ihr die waffe nicht mehr runter und zwar
so wie hier jetzt die waffe fest weil
sie außen rum fat bass und dann geht sie
eben nicht mehr kommt auf leisen weg
ich habe jetzt alle waffen ausgebacken
es schon dazu sagen wir mal die waffen
aus wachs wenn man spontan besucht
bekommt ein richter in der wohnung ein
bisschen nach frittierfett naja dann ist
es halt so die waffen sind ziemlich
knusprig geworden
und die sind echt so wie ich sie auch
kennen ich weiß dass meine oma früher
gemacht hat und ob er das gemacht hat
auf jeden fall kenne ich die von früher
und habe die echtzeit meiner kindheit
glaube ich nicht mehr gegessen ich
beschreibt die stadt die jetzt mit etwas
süßem schnee also puderzucker geht
natürlich auch aber das süße schnee
bleibt dann auch schön drauf liegen und
starter moratti prestige muss ich jetzt
probiert
ich glaube man hört wie knusprig
geworden sind also das ist wirklich
total lecker und man kann die auf jeden
fall
zwischendurch gerne mal machen gut drauf
sehr gut
falls sie jetzt auch lust bekommen habt
auf diese frittierten waffeln dann
schaut auf meinem blog sallys - blog.de
die zutaten sollst dir alle daheim haben
die hab ich zumindest immer mal
vorratsschrank und ich wünsche euch
jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken und wir sehen uns das nicht
immer wieder biss dann